menschliches verhalten lässt sich mit
luft ziemlich krass manipulieren
deswegen wird per von geschäften gezielt
als marketinginstrument eingesetzt um
uns zu manipulieren
doch dürfte können uns auch weiterhelfen
forschungsteams entdecken dass es
beispielsweise therapeutische mitte der
diagnose und therapie in der
krebsforschung seinen demenzkranken
können dürfte schon jetzt helfen krieg
zum science fiction
hier gibt es täglich faszinierendes 1
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
die geschichte des papas die ist echt
lang schon seit rund 5000 jahren etwa
setzen menschen dürfte ein
doch der zweck den pass zu erfüllen
hatten der hat sich stark verändert im
siebzehnten jahrhundert wurden sie zum
beispiel eingesetzt um unangenehme
körpergröße zu überdecken und somit das
waschen zu ersetzen
mit der aufklärung wandelte sich das
cover dann dagegen zum luxusprodukt und
heute weiß die wissenschaft menschen
suchen sich genau das paar aus dass den
eigenen körpergeruch verstärkt und das
hat biologisch gesehen auch wirklich
sinn
langfristiges ziel ist es dabei wohl die
sexuelle attraktivität bei biologisch
gut passenden partnern zu erhöhen
das konnte ein versuch eines deutschen
forschungsteams bereits vor einigen
jahren zeigen
die teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
entschieden sich nämlich für den duft
eines vaters der mit dem eigenen geruch
harmonisiert entscheidend dafür sind die
sogenannten mhc gene die stark
vereinfacht gesagt die merkmale des
immunsystems bestimmen und somit
letztendlich auch für den körpergeruch
des menschen verantwortlich sind
dieser sogenannte haupt desto
kompatibilitäts komplex im englischen
manchester kompatibilität komplex trägt
also die bauanleitung für ganz besondere
bausteine des immunsystems die ma c
proteine dieser mhc bausatz ist bei
jedem menschen sehr individuell und mit
hilfe einer gen-analyse festzustellen
für einen potenziellen paarungspartner
ist er aber quasi auch von außen
ablesbar daher wie eben schon erwähnt
unseren körper gropalis dazu manfred
milinski der an dem experiment damals
beteiligt war
wir erfassen
unbewusst wie die eigene immunabwehr
beschaffen ist und können die eines
potenziellen partners am geruch erkennen
diese gene einer versuchsperson
korrelierten in diesem versuch eng mit
ihren vorlieben für bestimmte gerüche
oder anders gesagt wie duft favoriten
der probanden verfügten in dem
experiment über das passende immun
genetische ergänzungs programm das den
potenziellen nachwuchs extrem zugute
kommen würde
riechen ist tatsächlich eine super
wichtige grundlage beide entscheidung
für den zukünftigen partner und das ist
nicht nur bei uns menschen so sondern
beispielsweise auch bei mäusen und
fischen
die natur hat sehr gut vorgesorgt denn
am geruch erkennt die frau oder aber
dass maus oder fisch weibchen die
sogenannten immun gene des potenziellen
partners die richtige mischung von immun
genen ist wiederum entscheidend für die
gesundheit der markt kommen und so
entscheidet frau beziehungsweise
weibchen sich für den partner
beziehungsweise für das männchen dessen
immun gene mit ihren eigenen die
optimale immunabwehr für die nachkommen
bietet und das heißt dann also auch
selbst wenn beim ersten date die
traumfrau oder der traumtyp schlechthin
vor uns steht egal wie humorvoll spontan
intelligent und gut aussehen die oder
der andere ist wenn man sich nicht
riechen kann geht da gar nichts aber
auch in der wirtschaft ist der einfluss
von düften schon längst erkannt worden
in geschäften in österreich albanien und
mazedonien beispielsweise bei der ganz
bestimmter duft eingesetzt damit sich
die kunden länger im geschäft aufhalten
düfte können laut wissenschaft
tatsächlich für ein besseres
einkaufserlebnis sorgen dazu der
bochumer riechforscher hanns hatt der
duft rief bei jeder entscheidung eine
wichtige rolle die meisten firmen denken
derzeit darüber nach
einen eigenen duft befinden in der
fachsprache wird das als sensorisches
marketing bezeichnet und könnte in
zeiten des boomende onlinehandel zu
einem markenzeichen mit hohem
wiedererkennungswert werden und es
funktioniert in einer pilotphase hielten
sich die kundinnen und kunden
tatsächlich länger in den filialen auf
wenn ein entsprechender duft eingesetzt
wurde heißt also im klartext
menschliches verhalten kann durch düfte
manipuliert werden das bochumer
forschungsteam um ans hat konnte das
auch in einem experiment zeigen hier
ging es um den blumigen duft stoff
namens mit tüll die hydro yaz monat kurz
edi on der tatsächlich
verhaltensänderung bei menschen auslöst
der stoff dockt an einen menschlichen
pheromone rezeptor an die testpersonen
reagierten dann laut der bochumer studie
freundlicher auf freundlichkeit aber
auch unfreundliche auf unfaires
verhalten heißt also wenn sowieso eine
gute stimmung herrscht wird diese durch
das medion verstärkt genauso aber auch
bei einer schlechten aggressiven oder
feindseligen stimmung experten und
expertinnen sprechen bei diesem phänomen
von einer verstärkung so genannter
reziproker verhaltensweisen und das
obwohl dieser duftstoff für die versuchs
teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer nicht
einmal wahrnehmbar in der luft gelegen
hatte doch nicht nur menschliche nasen
können wie ich ihn auch andere organe
wie etwa die haut die leber und die
nieren verfügen über duft rezeptoren und
auch an anderen körperstellen wie etwa
den haarwurzeln befinden sich geruch
sensoren die gebraucht werden um
chemische stoffe zu erkennen laut dem
duft forscher hans hatt aus bochum
könnten diese erkenntnisse genutzt
werden um langfristig gesehen neue
diagnose- und therapiemöglichkeiten für
krebserkrankungen zu entwickeln könnte
das wachstum der bösartigen krebszellen
verlangsamt oder sogar gestoppt werden
wenn die zellen mit genau dem duft
stimuliert werden auf denen ihre
rezeptoren ansprechen
laut dem bochumer experten verfügen
gesunde prostatazellen über einige
rezeptoren für veilchenduft
prostatakrebszellen dagegen seien
überhäuft mit genau solchen duft
rezeptoren doch bislang steckt die
forschung dazu noch in den kinderschuhen
bis duftstoffe tatsächlich noch in der
krebstherapie eingesetzt werden können
da ist es noch ein weiter weg unklar ist
beispielsweise noch
wie die duftstoffe in die krebszellen
geschleust werden können doch schon
jetzt werden dürfte eingesetzt um
menschen zu helfen
beispielsweise können bestimmte düfte
bei patientinnen und patienten mit
neurodegenerativen erkrankungen dafür
eingesetzt werden um schöne erinnerungen
in ihm wach zu wecken
auch ein altenheim in den usa setzt auf
diese idee die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner die nicht mehr fit genug sind
in senke stadion zu gehen tun dies
einfach durch den einsatz der
entsprechenden dürfte durch den duft
eines lederhandschuh werden erinnerungen
wach und manchen fällt sogar wieder ein
dass sie dem baseball star joe dimaggio
einst sogar selbst live im stadion
erlebt haben
top 10 verfügen neuerscheinungen neue
düfte für mann und frau 2019 wenn ihr
wissen wollt wie er am besten durfte
dann schaut euch dieses video germany an
also anklicken anschauen und auf jeden
fall den kanal abonnieren viele grüße an
jamie bis dann bleibt